- [Narrator] Shrinking
reservoirs, depleted aquifers,
drying rivers.
These images reveal the
scale of the mega drought
sweeping the American West.
It's the worst drought the region has seen
in at least 1,200 years.
With more pressure on water supplies,
one desert city offers a
promising conservation model.
- You fly into Vegas,
you see the Bellagio Fountains,
and you see the golf courses,
and it looks like a
land of absolute waste.
I've discovered that,
actually, Southern Nevada
is one of the most
water-minded places on Earth.
- [Narrator] Since 2002,
Southern Nevada has cut its
Colorado River water use by 26%
while also adding 750,000
people to its population.
Still, severe drought conditions
are forcing the region
to find even more ways to
reduce its consumption.
With the Colorado River Basin
at a dangerous tipping point,
here's how Las Vegas offers a roadmap
to making the most out
of every drop of water.
In June, the federal government
ordered unprecedented water
cutbacks asking Western states
to reduce their water
use by as much as 30%
to save the Colorado River system.
- The Colorado River
really is the lifeblood
of the American Southwest.
It runs for over 1,400 miles.
And along the way, it provides
water for 40 million people.
- [Narrator] As one of
the thirstiest cities
in the nation's driest state,
Las Vegas leaders realized
they couldn't afford
to gamble on water.
On average, Nevada receives
less than 10 inches
of rainfall a year.
It also gets the smallest amount of water
from the Colorado River.
- The Colorado River was divided up
about a hundred years ago
under the 1922 Colorado River Compact
where you had seven states
that were all negotiating
for how much water each
state would be allocated
from the river system.
At that time, with the
population that we had,
with the lack of potential for agriculture
here in our community sort of made sense
that perhaps Nevada did
only get a small amount.
- [Narrator] Decades later,
scientists discovered
the compact severely overestimated
how much water flows down
the Colorado River each year.
This over-allocation of water
combined with warming temperatures
and record-breaking drought
has the river system on
the verge of collapse.
At the same time, the constant pressure
on Las Vegas' water supply has
helped transform the region
into a leader in conservation.
(upbeat music)
The Bellagio Water Fountain
on the Las Vegas Strip
is one of the city's most
iconic and noticeable symbols
of excess water use.
The 8.5 acre man-made lake
holds more than 22
million gallons of water,
but nearly all of it is recycled.
- The thing that most people don't know
is that the Bellagio Fountain doesn't use
any of our community's water supply.
There is no Colorado
River water that is used
for that fountain.
It is fed by a private
well that pulls groundwater
and is owned by the hotel.
- [Narrator] Still, the
recycling system isn't perfect.
The fountain could lose
millions of gallons annually
to evaporation.
An MGM resort spokesperson
said they were committed
to using water responsibly
across the company
and supply chain.
- The Las Vegas Strip
obviously is the backbone
of our community, but
what's really interesting
is that it only uses about 5%
of our community's total water supply.
Residents who live here use 60%
So I don't know any other community
that makes a very small
investment of its water supply
to get such great economic returns.
- [Narrator] The Bellagio Fountain
represents just a fraction
of the region's water recycling efforts.
Nearly every drop of water used indoors
throughout Southern Nevada
is treated, recycled,
and returned in near-drinkable
quality to Lake Mead
according to the Clark County
Water Reclamation District.
In 2021, this accounted for about 50%
of the region's total water consumption.
- So the amount of water that
the Las Vegas Valley recycles
is absolutely unprecedented
in the Western United States.
- [Narrator] Dan Fischer
works at the largest
water recycling plant on
the Colorado River Basin.
- For every gallon of
water that we return,
we can take another gallon of water out.
Without our ability to recycle our water
and safely return it to
the lake and reuse it
because we treat it so
effectively, without those things,
Las Vegas wouldn't be what it is.
- [Narrator] To keep up with
rapid population growth,
the region's water recycling facilities
are nearly always under construction.
- The wastewater treatment
plants cannot get behind.
That is just not an option.
We have to stay ahead of it.
We have to keep building
more and more facilities
in order to be able to take that water
and effectively treat it
- [Narrator] Another way Las Vegas
is able to cut back on its water
is by removing one of its
biggest water guzzlers, grass.
- When you consider that
grass consumes 73 gallons
per square foot to survive
in the Mojave Desert,
you know, that's a column of
water that is 10 feet tall
for every square foot of grass.
- [Narrator] In 1999, the
Southern Nevada Water Authority
started its cash for grass program,
which currently pays homeowners
$3 for each square foot
of grass that's replaced
with water-efficient desert landscaping.
The region has removed
about 207 million square feet of grass
as a result of this policy.
- No place, really, in the American West
has been better than Las
Vegas at getting rid of grass.
It's spread to the rest of the West.
Phoenix is doing this.
Los Angeles now has
kind of a war on grass,
but Las Vegas really is the pioneer.
- [Narrator] More recently,
a new law in Southern Nevada,
the first of its kind in the nation,
bans non-functional grass.
That's the grass in medians and roadways
that is only planted
for decorative purposes.
Ecologists say grass lawns can also be bad
for desert ecosystems not meant to sustain
water-intensive plants.
- As of today, there are
approximately 3,000 acres
of non-functional grass.
Replacing that grass will save about 10%
of our community's overall water supply.
- [Narrator] Rigorous conservation efforts
don't just outlaw grass, but
also dictate when residents
can water their yards or wash their cars.
Water investigators like
this one patrol neighborhoods
to cite people who violate rules.
- We leave a courtesy door
hanger with a watering guide
letting them know, "Hey you're
not allowed to water today."
- I think it's important to note
that Southern Nevada did
not place conservation
on one sector.
We did not just require it of the resorts
down on the Las Vegas Strip.
We did not just require it of residents.
We placed conservation on the
backs of every single sector
in our community.
- [Narrator] As the drought
across the American West
worsens, reservoirs across the region
are reaching critical levels.
This summer, the country's
largest reservoir, Lake Mead,
fell to a record low.
- You see the pictures of Lake Mead,
you see the 200 feet of air
where there used to be water
for over the entire lake.
Unless the drought subsides,
we could get to a point where
Lake Mead cannot deliver
any water out of Hoover Dam.
That's a real possibility and
that's a terrifying thought.
- [Narrator] The federal government
says the seven Colorado River Basin states
still need to make more water cutbacks.
- And the Feds basically said,
if you don't do it voluntarily,
we reserve the right to make you,
we'll decide for you.
- [Narrator] All the basin states
said they recognized their shared role
in bringing the river system into balance.
More recently, California, the
region's largest water user
promised to reduce the state's
use of Colorado River water
by 400,000 acre feet every
year for the next three years.
Even as a leader in water conservation,
the Southern Nevada Water Authority
says Las Vegas is finding
more ways to cut back.
- It takes all sectors of your community
in order to contribute
to water conservation
and be successful.
And it's going to be the same
thing on the Colorado River.
It is going to take every
water user across every sector
to be contributing to the efforts
to reduce those water demands,
so that we can bring this
system back into balance.
(gentle music)